hello everyone and welcome to the fide
Women's World Chess Championship where
the Challenger elating Jay will
challenge the three times women's world
champion uh Jew wenjun uh for the title
at uh to be granted the dishonor letting
Jay had to defeat some very very strong
opponents uh in the uh women's
candidates tournament or rather in a
women's candidates matches uh she faced
Maria Anna music
the 2017 women's world champion and she
defeated all of them uh in the in the
quarterfinals she defeated Maria Musiq
by drawing three games and winning one
she defeated Adam was a joke in the
semi-finals also drawing three and
winning one and uh in the finals against
tanjonggir was a bit more difficult as
she lost the first game then she
retaliated in the second and then she
proceeded on winning the match grinding
her uh the uh well the honor and uh the
privilege of challenging you engine for
the title so uh the uh uh the the it it
will be a bit different than the World
Chess Championship between Nepal and the
ding there are some differences which we
are going to discuss it will be a 12
game match uh six games the first six
games will be played in juventions home
city of Shanghai and the rest of the
match will be played in
um uh late in Jay's hometown of
Chongqing so six games here six games
there and of course if there will be tie
breaks I believe they will be also
continued in uh tinje's Hometown I don't
think they will be you know flying back
as it's it's a pretty big distance if
you guys are considering going there in
person to watch the games it's like a
1700 kilometers between
um uh the two cities uh you know if
you're not into the metric system that's
like uh 1 000 miles so uh you know
something to consider if you are
consider considering visiting uh but
okay that being said let's now cons uh
discuss the the time control and the
price from the price fund also uh
somewhat uh less than in the open World
Series championship between nepon ending
it was a 2 million euros here it's a 500
000 Euros and it's uh it's also a
different time control uh here the time
control is uh 90 minutes for the first
40 moves followed by 30 minutes to the
end of the game with a 30 seconds uh
increment starting from move one which
is a bit different uh than when a nipple
played against the ding uh here uh Nepal
and ding had 120 minutes for the first
40 moves then 60 minutes for the next 20
moves and then 15 minutes for the rest
of the game with a 30 seconds uh
increment starting only after move 61 or
rather starting only for move 61. so I
don't know which one I prefer I kind of
like
um I mean I I prefer that in the Women's
World Championship you get less time uh
for for the game so of course the game
should be should be sharper but also I
don't like in the Women's World
Championship that you get increments
starting from move one uh that kind of
takes away the tension from the game I
really enjoyed it you know if you you're
down on time you're not getting
increment you have to reach that time
control to be granted increment and
basically in the open World Championship
the increment is something that is used
if you already reach the end game and
you really need time to finish the end
game so I don't know which one I prefer
I'm guessing uh I'm guessing from the
from the uh nepo ding because I really
hate uh 30 seconds increment starting
from move one but I don't know also I
also like the shorter time control here
for for the entire game so what do you
guys think and also something that I'm
sure that will be asked here as it's
asked in every video uh where we are
showing uh uh women playing chess uh a
lot of you will ask why is there a
separate men and women's uh chess now
that's not really true there is no men's
chess in women's chess there are women
tournaments yes that is true but you
don't have men's tournaments you only
have open tournaments uh so uh in if you
if you think about it women have access
to all the tournaments that are being
played in the world they can play in an
instrument and men can only play in open
turns they cannot join women's
tournaments at least for the moment
unless
um you know the trend progresses to
chess but uh you know it's uh not as
great as it seems although it seems like
women have a lot more opportunities to
go to tournaments and play uh the prize
fund as you can see here the price fund
is basically a quarter of the price fund
that uh was in the world's championship
match between nepo and ding uh the uh
not only is it um a smaller price fund
but also as uh you know it's it's harder
for women to compete with men at the
moment uh it will also be harder for
them to actually win in open tournaments
so uh you know it's uh definitely a
trade-off but yeah I just wanted to
clear that up so there are no men and
women tournaments there are only women
tournaments and open tournaments now uh
let's check out the game uh We've uh
this is game four that I will be
covering uh uh first three games I've
checked them now a lot not a lot of
action there in game one uh Jewel engine
did have some maybe sort of an
initiative but nothing serious like even
the engine was struggling to give it
maybe even a plus one like maybe 0.8
plus one and not nothing you know
nothing serious uh game two and game
three were fairly quick draws and now we
are into in game four so if you have any
other questions I will be more than
happy to answer them uh we will also be
Pro probably will be covering all of the
uh other games until the end of the
match uh do just ask and I will answer
them in the next video but now okay it's
a bit of a longer intro but I always
give a longer intro when I'm only
starting a certain tournament or or a
match uh we are not going to do that in
the other videos of the match so that
being said let's check out the game uh
lady has the white pieces and she opens
with Pawn to D4 Jewel engine replies
Pawn to D5 we have C for E6 Knight to F3
and now Knight to F6 we have Knight to
C3 and D captures on C4 so the three
nice variation of the Queen's Gambit 3D
captures on C4 and now Pawn to E4 we
have pawned the B5 defending the
opponent C4 and now Pawn to E5 we've
seen this variation quite a lot um uh
recently Knights the D5 and now Knight
captures on B5 we have Knights the B6
and now uh as the C4 Pawn is defended uh
Bishop T2 just preparing the castle with
Knight to C6 and now Castle so all been
seen before absolutely nothing new here
Bishop D7 and now there even is a game
that Magnus Carlsen played against the
antipomishi and Magnus lost this game to
nepo he played it in the Magnus Crossing
Invitational Quinta D2 was played here
by Magnus but instead we have Bishop to
E3 here which is the top move
recommended by the engine so the 18j
yeah definitely prepared well uh we have
castles and now Knight the C3 but again
this is all known Theory uh Rook to B8
and now Pawn to B3 challenging the C4
Pawn uh you always uh it's kind of a uh
well it's kind of a thing in chess to
challenge a more Central Pawn with a
less Central opponent here the B Pawn is
challenging the C Pawn so C captures
them B3 a capture some B3 now you also
get the semi-open a file for your rook
and Bishop to B7 we have Queen to B1 uh
and now Knight to B4 now you could uh
also just not give up the pawn on A7 but
it's very hard to get an active game
here as black uh with with the pawn on
A7 okay the Knight is defending it but
the the Knight cannot move the pawn
cannot move you can't really put it to
A6 as the bishop and The Rook are
controlling that square if you put it to
A5 again the Knight cannot move the
bishop cannot come alive so it's best uh
just uh ignore it Knight the B4 was
played this opens up The Bishop's
diagonal also gives the Knight a very
active Square now the other Knight is
coming to D5 and Black's position uh
definitely comes alive and there is a
game where Rook captures an A7 was
played uh yakubo have played it against
Parham Maxwell their game ended in a
draw but here we have Knight to E4
instead of going after the pawn right
away and now comes Pawn to H6 there is a
game where Ponte A6 was played But Here
pawn to H6 and it is now only as of move
15 that we have a completely new game so
okay Rook captures on A7 and now Knight
six the D5 with Bishop to D2 of course
not allowing the capture the bishop pair
is very important here if you don't have
to give it up you shouldn't uh Knight to
C6 and now Rook back to A1 The Rook on
A7 is attacked so it kind of overstayed
it's welcome uh Knight to D back to B4
and now Bishop back to E3 defending the
pawn here and preparing Rook to D1 so
Knight back to D5 attacking the bishop
and now Bishop to C1 obviously if the
bishop to D2 maybe zooming repeats
Knight to B4 maybe we would see a
three-fold repetition uh and of course
you do not want to squander the white
pieces just like that so that's why of
course Bishop to C1 Rook to A8 and now
Rook to D1 The Rook will be much more
useful here defending the before and
also it's very nicely positioned Rook
capture Sunny one Queen captures and now
Knight seat the B4 we have knighted to
C5 now putting pressure on the bishop
here and just Bishop to C6 so also uh
keeping the bishop pair with Bishop to
D2 and now Queen to ba trying to
introduce the queen into the game
somehow uh we have Queen to A5 now uh
putting a pressure on that Queen side
and also the Rook really no longer needs
to stay on the one Rook to see one is
coming and there will be a lot of work
for this Rook on the C file we have Rook
to d8 and now Rook the C1 now if the
Knight moves you you have to be careful
not to lose that Bishop we have Queen to
B6 offering a queen trade and um uh
things really obliges we have characters
captures and now Knight to A6 offering a
trade of knights but just Bishop to B7
also you have to be careful if Knight
captures Knight then also Rook captures
Bishop could be possible so both of them
just keeping their appears intact we
have knighted the C7 now and pawn to G5
grabbing more space on the king side
also preparing G4 which might weaken the
D4 Pawn could be important later on uh
so they just stops it we have H3 and now
Knight to F4 and here uh The Bishop's
pair uh it's a very hard it's not easy
to keep the bishop pair here you really
want to play Knight to F1 to control the
Knight but then Bishop captures Knight
is definitely coming and this is really
gonna weaken White's King side messing
up the pawn structure and everything so
instead Knight to F4 we have Bishop
captures on F4 G captures on F4 now uh
Juan Jun uh willingly doubles her F Pawn
and it introduces some imbalance in the
in the position uh well this is
definitely a way to play for for more
than a draw we have Knights the B5 now
preparing Rook to C7 this would be
excellent you know that once The Rook
reaches the seventh rank it becomes a
pig and then it just gobbles everything
up so of course that needs to be
prevented with Bishop to C6 the bishop
is safe here as it's very hard to
disrupt the Knight on B4 that's
defending the bishop so King to F1 uh
lighting J just starts bringing the king
into the game and juven June does the
same King to f8 Rook to D1 and now Rook
to AAA trying to get the Rook uh also on
A2 also the rook and A2 is basically the
seventh rank from Black's perspective so
also uh wants to promote her Rook to a
pig with Knight to C3 of course stopping
that and now Knights the A2 removing the
stopper uh so Knight captures an A2 Rook
captures an A2 and now Knights the E1
okay you can attack the b-pawn but then
the Knight is coming uh for the F for
the F Pawn so Rook the B2 we have
Knights to D3 and now Rook captures and
B3 Knight captures an F4 so it's a bit
easier giving up the F4 Pawn is it's a
doubled pawn and now you also have the
pass B Pawn so it's a bit of a trade-off
as you can see uh La is uh up up a pawn
but dual engine is uh well not up
anything but she does have the best
repair so you have the bishop pair uh
the rook and the past B Pawn now I don't
know uh what you guys would choose the
extra Pawn or the bishop pair in the
past B Pawn but I have a pretty good
idea what you would choose so here we
have Bishop at A3 now trying to position
the Bishops perfectly to advance that
pawn and now Pawn to D5 you can't really
wait and do nothing if you give black a
few moves then she will just uh uh you
know position her pieces properly and
start advancing that pawn so here you
have to react to the pawn thrust of
course e captures on D5 Knight captures
on D5 and now Bishop to C5 now the
bishop fair is fully operational and
it's not gonna be easy to get that white
king into the game Knight to F6 and now
we have Rook the B2 uh now you again you
have to be very careful the idea could
be Bishop characters and G2 check then
the king captures and then you pick up
the bishop here you win another Pawn you
miss a white spawn structure uh you
would not be not be very happy here so
how can you stop this well there are a
couple of moves you could play you could
play Knight a D7 check which is
interesting of course uh it seems that
either you give up this bishop or white
will capture this bishop it will but let
the king t7 now Knight captures and c5b
captures and C5 this is not past C pawn
and let's say Bishop to C4 now with some
ideas of maybe even going after the
uh maybe even going after the F7 Pawn uh
Rook the C2 attacks the bishop price to
get his uh her pass steep on uh down the
board Bishop to D3 Rook to B2 and now
Bishop to C4 will Rook to B4 Bishop to
D5 let's say offering a trail of Bishops
and now if you really want to keep the
Bishop's Bishop to B5 with checking the
G1 and now Pawn to C for the pawn would
start marching down the board but you
can also play Rook to C1 and it will be
very very hard to actually push that
pawn down the board and let's say F6 F4
and even if you trade here all of these
squares are now covered by the bishop
and by the pawn so yes uh it's not it's
definitely not much you're down a pawn
and uh okay it's already a pass ball and
C4 but you are down a pawn and you don't
really have all that uh many ideas on
how to continue this so it's not the
best so instead of that after this Rook
the BT move we don't have Knight to D7
right away we first have fonte F4 now
what's the idea behind Pawn to F4 is now
is after Ponte F4 Bishop characters and
G2 even an idea let's do Play Bishop
captures on G2 King captures and Rook
captures ESU one upon but now King to F3
and if Rook to E3 checking to G4 and now
if you evaluate this position once the
king comes to F5 it's a light square or
the king can even go after the uh the H
Pawn to win another one if this Rook
stops for example attacking the H3 Pawn
uh it just seems like you've given a
white too much activity for for grabbing
that one Pawn so instead after Pawn to
F4 we don't have Bishop captures and G2
Rook the B for his plate going after the
F4 pawn and now lay just goes for G3
defends the df4 pawn we have rooked the
B3 now attacking the B3 pawn and you can
see how it's very hard for the king to
help out with any of this as the bishop
Perry is doing such marvelous work uh
now we have Knight to D7 with check now
again if you wanted to maybe try
something like Rook to D3 because you
really don't want to trade you really
want to keep the tension here black can
always just repeat Rook to B1 with check
and you have to move back so it's not
really an option so instead I have to
Rook the B3 we have knighted D7 with
check and now you can have two options
and none of them are what you want to
play because if you play King the E7
then Knight captures and C5 and after B
captures let's take into F2 you defend
your Pawn uh okay you're just down a
pawn and we have Bishops of the same
color so if anyone is better here it's
definitely white it doesn't really
matter that you have a past C Pawn so of
course it's better to trade differently
in the game Bishop captures and D7 was
played Rook captures and now also Rook
captures and G3 so now it's equal
material and the Bishops are of opposite
color so unless you really mess
something up here it will be a draw so
Bishop to G4 we have Rook the E3 and now
King to G2 we have Bishop to E7 and Rook
to B7 so very nicely done placing the
Rook behind the pass Pawn now comes Pawn
to F6 we have pawned the E6 creating a
pass Pawn Here and Now Pawn to H5 trying
to trade this Pawn for this Pawn but of
course you're not gonna do that Bishop
to F5 we have Pawn to H4
not allowing the king to go any further
and now Bishop to G4 we have rooked to
G3 with checking to have to end the
bishop to C5 with the check with King to
F1 and now Bishop back to E7 of course
you you cannot allow Rook to F7 check
you have to move the bishop back Bishop
t7 was played King to E2 and now Rook
the B3 we have Pawn to F5 and now Pawn
to B5 we have King to D2 and now Pawn to
B4 so the pawn is now nicely defended if
you can somehow get the The Rook down
the board maybe continue pushing the
pawn good things might happen but the
white Rook is already behind the pass
pawn and that's never never good for you
Rook the B8 check with King to G7 and
now Rook the E8 going after the bishop
but now just Bishop to D6 we have Rook
to d8 attacking the bishop Bishop p7
Rook to E8 Bishop to B6 Rook 38 Bishop
to E7 rook d8 and he was in this
position on move 63 that team JLA and
Juan Jun agreed to a draw or rather it's
a draw by threefold repetition so it was
a was an interesting game white was uh
well she was up upon but you went Jun
had the bishop pair in the past b-pawn
so like I said it's a trade-off at some
point
um La TJ had to give back the pawn and
you had this well very very equal end
game with the Bishops of opposite color
so that's game four of the affiliate
Women's World Chess Championship hope
you enjoyed it like I said I will I will
be covering uh all of them until the end
of the end of the tournament so we'll
see what happens in the other uh in the
other games and like I said in the
beginning I was thinking because it's a
shorter time format than we've had in
the nepoding rotary championship match I
thought the games will be a lot more
active but for some reason they aren't
and probably probably and this is only
my opinion I I haven't really read that
anywhere it's probably due to the time
control being um uh well 30 30 seconds
increment being given already on move
one so that you you know you're never in
trouble you know that whatever happens
if you are you know swimming safely in
the protected Waters of theory nothing
bad will happen to you in the 30 seconds
increment starting from move one will
always uh well keep the position stimid
so I think that even though uh uh a
nipple ending had more time in the
actual classical games for the first 40
moves and then for the next 20 I think
that uh giving time control starting
only after move 60 is the way to go but
I could be wrong on this maybe you guys
have a different take on this uh so yeah
that's the game I hope you guys enjoyed
it we'll see what happens in game five
and the rest of the uh rest of the event
I would like to thank James Eugene
Cashman Paul Miller Brad Michael
Marshall and bullet just thriller.com
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up uh on your wonderful
suggestions and everything else that's
happening in the Chess World also while
covering the fide women's world
championship match thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day